حمل العامه 20 22
للعالم تحديات عده ابرزها على سبيل المثال
للحصر زياده التضخم والتقلبات المناخيه
القاسيه والحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا التي
لا تزال تلقي بظلالها على العالم باسرها
اقله بازمه الطاقه لكن رغم مقاس سهل
العالم من ازمات هناك اسباب تدعو للتفاؤل
بالعام المقبل وما بعده بحسب صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز لعل ابرز ذلك اقتراب
الاكتشافات العلميه قليلا من الطموح الذي
طال اما ده بشان الوصول الى علاج لمرض
السرطان لنتعرف واياكم على ابرز ما يدعون
للتفاؤل بالعام 20 23 اقترب العلماء من
مصدر جديد للطاقه نظيفه بعد تقدم كبير في
الاندماج النووي كما عرفت وصل العلماء
الامريكيون في كاليفورنيا الى هذا الانجاز
خلال ديسمبر ولا يزال هناك عقود قبل ان
يصبح الاندماج النووي مصدرا فعليا للطاقه
في سوق المال تم تتفاؤل لدى وست ستريت
واصحاب راس المال بشان التكنولوجيا
الخضراء اذ يشهد استثمار راس المال الخاص
في هذا القطاع ارتفاعا مع انفاق 70 مليار
دولار على مدار العام الماضيين ومنذ ذلك
الحين تستمر التقنيات الجديده لمعالجه
قضايا المناخ في الظهور من احداث 20 22
التطور في مجال الروبوتات التي لن تحل
مكان الانسان في الوظائف حتى الان ولكن
ستجعل المهمات اسهل فما يمكن ان تفعله
الروبوتات بشكل جيد هو تسهيل العمل الشاق
ومساعده الانسان بشكل اكبر في مجالات عده
طبيه اقترب الخبراء في 20 22 من تطوير
لقاحات السرطان ولا طالما اعتقد الباحثون
انه من الممكن تحصيل الافراد المعرضين على
خطر الاصابه به او علاج السرطان لدى اولئك
الذين ظهرت عليهم علامات الاصابه
وحتى وقت قريب لم يحرز الخبراء سوى تقدم
من ضئيل لكن النتائج الواعده من الدراسات
الاوليه تمنح بعض الاطباء املا جديدا شركه
مديرنا قالت هذا الشهر ان لقاح سرطان
الجلد كان اداؤه جيدا في منتصف المرحله
التجريبيه وتعمل مديرنا واخرون على عشرات
اللقاحات الاخرى لعلاج مختلف انواع
السرطان خلال العام الحالي عرض تلسكوب
جيمنج الفضائي المجرات البعيده والقديمه
للمره الاولى ويبدو ان مهمته ستدهشون اكثر
العمل مقبل بالكثير من الصور والمعلومات
المهمه جدا عن كوننا الفسيح